hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round seven of the
fide candidates tournament 2022 uh it's
a game that pretty much everyone uh that
was commenting on the game proclaimed a
draw uh very very early on because the
position that happened on the board uh
was in fact an objective draw it was an
incredible preparation by nipponishi who
employed the petra of defense to secure
um just a very very early drawing when i
said draw i mean as a 0.00 draw uh with
an engine evaluation uh but a rapport
decided to push even though uh he he
knew that he was probably going into
some uh extreme preparation so it's it's
a wonderful game and it uh really shows
the the will a rapport had to play on
even though he didn't want to squander
the white pieces he just wanted to
make make some use of them uh from a
really really difficult position as
you'll see uh like i said very early on
so an output with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have e5 by nipple knight to
f3 nipple goes for knight to f6 the
petrol of defense knight captures an e5
and d6 knight back to f3 so nothing out
of the ordinary knight captures d4 and
d5 we have bishop to d3 and the bishop
to d6 castles and uh
nipple also castle so this is the
martial variation of the classical
attack of the petrov uh c4 c6 and now
the usual ideas here are knight to c3
queen to c2 putting more pressure on the
knight is also played c captures and e5
is a known move and there are a couple
of moves that are
somewhat rarer but the queen to b3 the
mover upward place is uh incredibly rare
uh and uh well this is what he prepared
for nipple here uh but nepal not very
impressed he uh immediately plays bishop
to g4 he says all right go after your b7
pawn i'm just gonna grab the knight on
f3 and that's it and this would uh
really be terrible for a rapport if he
goes for this if if the queen captures
bishop counters and queen captures an a8
then you have a forced checkmate bishop
captures on h5 king captures queen to h4
with check king g1 and now queen g4 will
be checkmate so now obviously you don't
you don't want to do that so instead we
have bishop captures on e4 uh there are
a couple of other games for example
knight b to d2 is a known move uh nigel
short defeated hari krishna with this
idea but bishop captures an e4 is a new
move so now already as of move 10 we
have a completely new game
which is uh incredible in itself as this
is the petrov so here d captures on e4
and now knight the g5 and now what can
uh what can nipple do here well he just
goes bishop back to e7 he wants to get
rid of this knight
and he says uh well just move it so
knight captures an e4 rapper grabs d4
pawn and nipple plays a queen captures
on d4 but now obviously queen captures
on b7 is happening and this is pretty
much where everyone thought okay it's a
draw because we all see what's happening
it's going to be a forced bishop
sacrifice and that's it so queen
captures on b7 queen capture an e4
rapport plays the strongest move but it
is just uh another very promising one
queen captures an a8 and now nipple goes
for bishop to h3 threatening checkmate
already on move 15 and there is no other
move you have to capture on h3 otherwise
um uh you can just forget about it so g
captures on h3 queen to g6 check king to
h1 and queen to e4 with check and here
in airport saying okay this is what i
have against this if kg1 we're just
going to repeat we call it a day uh we
didn't spend all that much time we
prepare for the other half of the of the
candidates tournament but here uh
rapport went into a very very deep thing
uh for some half an hour long and for
the other moves another half an hour so
basically to decide whether he wants to
continue the game or whether he wants to
repeat uh he spent about an hour
and since i forgot to show it to you in
in the beginning here is just a nice
photo of of the two of them
before the actual game there we have it
uh this gentleman making the first movie
if any of you guys know who it is uh do
share in the comments so we can learn as
well and as usual if you notice anything
weird about the photo uh also to mention
in the comments as i very much enjoy uh
such findings and now getting back to
the position after queen to e for check
king to g1 a repetition queen to g6
checking the h1 and queen to e4 check
and here rapport did not play king to g1
instead he played a pawn to f3 and now
what do you play here it's again uh
nipple has to has a has to play a series
of only moves in order to just survive
this because if queen captures on c4
which seems like a pretty good idea
you're gonna play king to g2 you have to
defend the rook here and now after let's
say bishop c5 you're gonna play knight
to c3 and after queen to a6 uh hoping to
trap the white queen here because that's
kind of black's plan after giving up
this rook the queen has no way of
exiting you want to play knight to d7
and win the white queen there's the
tricky rook to e1 this is how white wins
and now after knight d7 there's rook to
e8 and now white is just winning so you
have to uh
defend against this so instead of queen
to d3 now the idea is that uh we are
attacking rook and if king to g2 we're
gonna play queen to g6 and this is the
other part where uh rappers really had
to decide whether he wanted to continue
and he spent an additional half an hour
does he want to just repeat with king g2
queen g6 king back to h1 queen to d3 or
he wants to play something else so here
we have king to g2 queen to g6 repeating
once king to h1 queen to d3 and now he
doesn't go for this but rather knight to
d2 and here rapport is saying i know i'm
uh you know going into your preparation
but i cannot just wonder the white
pieces like this i i have to at least
try even though it comes with uh
well
with the price of a queen sacrifice so
here we have queen to d7 this is the
only move we have to prevent the white
queen from escaping via the b7 square uh
so queen to d7 and now uh we have knight
the e4 by rapport and this is a very
nice idea guarding the d6 square also
the bishop is coming to f4 or e3
and we are saying uh well at some point
we will move the knight and you will not
have
any square for your queen so knight's
day six attacking the queen this is what
nepal goes for uh and now you have to
give up the queen there is no other way
and this is where rapper plays queen
captures an f8 so grabbing the other
rook as well and this is uh basically
the first moment in the game where nepo
started thinking he had to recall
whether uh bishop captures an uh fate or
king captures and if it was the correct
idea uh because he probably thought that
even though he checked that this this
position wouldn't and there's no way
this position happens in a candidate
starting because who would be uh you
know uh so so uh interested in playing a
position like this i mean who would be
crazy enough to to go into this
but a rapport would and so this is the
first moment that uh where nepo uh has
to consider so obviously you could
capture with the king he captures with
the bishop the king here is just a bit
awkward you never want your king and
your bishop like this then if you
receive some sort of a back rank check
then you always have to
give up the bishop and so it just looks
weird so instead bishop captures an f8
and now we have bishop to f4 you have to
develop the bishop somehow bishop to e3
bishop to f4 uh so bishop to e3 also
makes sense as it regards the c5 square
so it really makes it uh
hard for this knight to enter the game
but he goes for bishop to f4 he wants to
play bishop to g3 so after nipple
captures on h3 he doesn't have to
have the rook on f1 to defend the f3
pawn and okay nipple goes for the h3
pawn
rook 8 to d1 now he wants to play rook 8
to d8 to put pressure on this bishop if
he can get rook 8 to d8 and bishop to d6
then he doesn't have to worry about
anything anymore
uh so bishop onto h6 uh making a little
bit of breeding room for the king here
and now comes uh bishop to g3 and this
is the
first moment where things start to go
wrong for rapport here the a3 is a much
needed move because you know that
nipples playing knight to c5 and this
just allows you to
really minimize the power of the
dark square bishop currently placed on
f8 because here the bishop isn't doing
all that much if nepo activates it then
it's a problem and here the knight to c5
line which is pretty much the the best
thing apple has
runs into b4 that's the problem and now
after the bishop moves we play c5 we
don't allow
black the mess up our pawn structure
here and now the bishop is not as useful
and yeah it's it's a very very tricky
position for example g5 you play bishop
to d6 and all of a sudden you have
nothing to worry about black can't trade
because you get a beautiful past pawn if
black just moves the bishop let's say
bishop f6 then rapper can even break
through with b5 if captures then the c
pawn starts marching forward again
made possible by the pawn being on b4
make no mistake there so after this h6
rapport went for bishop to g3 instead
and now you don't have this luxury of
playing b4 as you have not prepared it
with a3 so nipple quickly plays knight
to c5 and now it's a little bit
different you can't trade
the problem is after you trade now uh
the bishop here is just too powerful you
don't have time to kick it away for
example if a3 we play a5 good luck
playing b4 for the rest of the game and
now let's say rook to d80 check you can
make some threats here let's say rook
after d1 now h5 with h4 coming and it's
just much much worse it is completely uh
winning for for nipple so this is not um
what you can do here so instead rook f2
e1 by rapport and now nipple goes for
knight to e6 you could also trade here
that's also possible for example you
trade captures captures and you play g5
there's also nothing wrong with that uh
but nipple goes for a very very
different idea knight to e6 we have a3
now with uh b4 and c5 in mind and now h5
of course nepal wants to play h4 we have
rook to d3 trying to bait nipple into
playing h4 because this defends it uh
with a tactic if you play h4 now then
knight f2 attacks the queen
and uh the rook uh defends the pawn so
once you move the queen the pawn is
defended then you can just gobble up the
h4 pawn so there's that so nipple
doesn't fall for this he plays queen to
f5 uh the situation on the clock 30
minutes for rapport and an hour and 21
minutes for for nipple uh so really
enjoying his time there and now finally
rapport plays ponte v4 it's uh there is
really isn't a better move in the
position only here
uh pretty much every move is uh winning
for for nepo but you have to uh find one
very particular idea that uh wins the
game uh so feel free to pause the video
and to win this incredible game for
yanni pumashi uh while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible pawn sacrifice and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course ponte h4 that's the good
stuff and now you don't really have an
option here you can't move the bishop
and you can't really capture on h4 uh or
rather you have to place uh one of one
of those two options if you capture here
it's nothing good just uh knights to f4
attacks the rook and now the knight has
all sorts of nasty discoveries for
example if you play a rook d the e3 to
still keep an eye on the f3 pawn we can
just play queen h3 and now we're
threatening the bishop and also
threatening checkmate so this is resigns
and if you move the rook somewhere else
let's say try rook to d4 it's not much
better we're going to play knight the g6
now attack the bishop with the knight
also we're attacking the f3 pawn because
now the rook doesn't defend the pawn and
no
no problems there whatsoever so
that's uh uh that's what happens if you
actually capture this pawn so what can
uh what can a rapper do well he plays
bishop back to b8 now maybe he can grab
the a7 pawn and then he can start
marching his own past pawns forward uh
but uh now just knight to g5 by nepo
sorry not knight to g5 um
not knight to g5 by rapper knight to g5
by nepo uh he could improve on the
position further with c5 but um
he goes for knight to g5 right away and
now we have rook d to e3 now the only
way to kind of continue playing is rook
eat the e3 but it's such an ugly move to
make yes you are defending the f3 pawn
twice but still just knight captures
here rook captures and now h3 this is
just uh disgusting to even look at for
white however maybe with perfect play
maybe one could hold this but after rook
d the e3 now there is nothing now okay
and uh the df3 pawn still cannot be
captured if you capture this it would be
a pretty big blunder we just play rook
to f1 and now you really don't have
anything better than to go after the
bishop brook captures an f3 queen
captures here in rook captures on f7
this is now something white will uh
very likely hold to a draw uh but after
knight captures an e4 now uh rapport
realizes that there is no more holding
this f captures an e4 queen to f2 now a
beautiful move uh preventing rooks from
doing anything because if you attack the
queen with this rook this is checkmate
and if you attack the queen with this
rook it's not much better just queen f3
checking g1 h3 and uh well this is a
light square good luck defending this
you have a dark square bishop your rooks
can't really move anywhere
it's just uh
incredibly
ugly to even look at i i have to uh you
know say it like that so after queen to
f2 uh we have h3 not allowing nipple to
push h3 and now just bishop to e7 now we
have all the time in the world to
activate this bishop and we will do that
via the e7 and g5 squares so bishop to
h2 and now we're trying to kick away the
queen with bishop g1 let's still bishop
g5 we have bishop to g1 queen to d2 and
now again what do you play uh you have
to play something your rook is hanging
uh if you go after the queen here then
we play queen to c1 and again your rook
is hanging the c4 pawn is saying there's
just no good way to play this if you you
can
there's really nothing to do you're
gonna have to attack the queen one more
time then we capture on c4 and then once
your pawn starts uh falling uh there's
just not all that much you can do it's a
it's uh it's a sad position uh so
instead rook three to e2 was played
attacking nepo's queen this way but now
just queen to d3 and here rapper has
four minutes and the clock nepo has over
an hour and
uh here you we can even uh check a nice
photo of this moment here you can see a
nipple circling uh uh
rapport like you know like like a
a vulture circling his prey uh very very
nicely done there uh the two of them uh
just you know
nipple leading the tournament rappers
trying to get anything but a draw in
this tournament and here he uh over
pushed a little bit with the white
pieces but you just don't want to be
shut down like that right out of the
opening uh so here
again not much to do the h3 pawn is
hanging if you play king here then we
just deliver queen g3 check and then
pick up the pawn so bishop p3 pretty
much only thing left and now nipple
doesn't even go for queen captures an e4
with check because that would kind of
put his queen into some line of fire uh
we can even show it for example if this
check king g1 now we're going to play
bishop to f6 there's a bishop captures
on a7 we attack the queen we create some
past pawn he's here uh and okay queen
captures and see for the game continues
uh nepo will win this position but he
doesn't even allow this he plays bishop
to f6 and um
is without the move pretty much he plays
bishop captures on a7 but now queen
captures an h3 with check king to g1 we
have queen to g3 king to f1 and pawn to
h3 we have bishop back to g1 stopping
pawn to h2 but now just bishop to h4 and
he was in this position on move 43 after
reaching time control that uh rihard
rapport resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so jan went into uh the round seven as
the leader of the candidates tournament
and he finishes round seven as the
leader of the candidates tournament so
it pretty much depends how uh it depends
how other players will uh you know
finish their games but uh so far uh nepo
is leading by a full point and a half
so even even even if fabi wins this game
uh and if it will still be leading by by
half a point so
definitely uh
nicely done going into the
second half of the tournament uh we're
going to cover the other games and check
out what happened there as well but in
case you're wondering why this is
resigns uh what do you play here you
have to play something uh that doesn't
really matter if you play any move then
the threat is just queen to f3 check
there's no defending this if you block
with the bishop this is checkmate if you
block with the rook it's not much better
we just capture here captures the bishop
captures h2 we uh promote the pawn on
the next movie it's gonna be checkmate
and if you don't play something like c5
uh yeah you could play some like rook to
f2 it doesn't really matter still just
h2 with check and now uh uh you either
capture with the bishop then we capture
here with checkmate or you capture with
the rook then we capture here you have
to go to g2 i mean it's uh the queen it
captures on e4 uh
impossible to to play this with white it
will be resigned very soon so yeah after
uh queen to h4 rapport agrees that there
is no point continuing this and uh he
resigned in this position so
incredibly incredible game where as you
can see very early on like i said uh
everyone agreed that um
this was just going to be after queen
captures and b7 a very quick draw
because well of course the bishop h3 and
we call it a draw
but araparte did not want a 15 move draw
with the white pieces he went into a
deep thing spent over an hour
and well tried to sacrifice his queen
for some sort of an attack and you know
if nepo did not have everything
absolutely prepared but he just played
the the moves instantly and uh he knew
exactly what to do so it was uh there
were there was no possibility that this
would go uh you know in rapper's way in
in in any scenario
in case someone asks you what happened
in the game and you want to explain it
to them in like one sentence that's what
what happened
uh so yeah once again i really hope you
guys enjoyed that uh very commendable uh
by by rapport for going for it but he
makes it much much harder for him and
the other players to catch up to nipple
who is uh
definitely snowballing the the
candidates so far
uh so yeah once again i really hope you
enjoyed it i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to sophia and i would
like to thank hans anderson amarillo
accounting spanish accountant in uk
jakub gonzalez and stephen mcneil for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day